we have a morning must watch today and
for we turn to Las Vegas and that
dramatic debate between the two
principal candidates for president most
of the headlines this morning about the
pyrotechnics but in truth there was a
fair amount of substance address by both
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump for
example mr. Trump had an extended
discussion with the moderator chris
wallace of fox news about his plan for
economic growth here's part of it even
conservative economists who have looked
at your plans say that the numbers don't
add up that your idea and you've talked
about 25 million jobs created four
percent over junior growth is
unrealistic and they say you talk a lot
about growing the energy industry so I
just left some high representatives of
India they're growing at eight percent
China is growing at seven percent and
that for them is a catastrophic lelo
number we are growing our last report
came out and it's right around the one
percent level and I think it's going
down so joining us now is Mike McKee he
is our politics and economics editor of
course joining us almost every day which
I've been happy to say so Mike as I say
there was a fair amount of substance
here that was addressed by both of these
candidates take us into it what what
real difference would it make for the US
economy if Donald Trump for president
versus Hillary Clinton well there'd be a
huge difference according to the people
who have analyzed these things folks
from Wharton with the most recent study
out suggesting that trumps plan would
create jobs and boost the economy in the
short run because it's extraordinary
deficit spending with the big tax cuts
over the longer run it would cost jobs
and the economy would be smaller than it
otherwise would if his plan was not
adopted the opposite happens with
Hillary Clinton in the shorter run
because she raises taxes and cuts more
spending you're going to have a slower
pace of growth fewer jobs created over
the longer run and they're talking 2020
and beyond you have more jobs created
and greater growth about a 4 10 swing
Trump's plan by 2020 would cost about
four tenths of gdp while the clinton
plan would raise gdp above its baseline
by 14 now there's some range with the
experts and how they evaluate this
because other people will say about mr.
trump's plan it doesn't cost as much as
you just said and in fact we're under
estimating the amount of
it would actually be given us including
because of his trade his restrictions on
trade well a couple points there one
it's very hard to evaluate the Trump
plan because it's the detail free
especially his tax plans he doesn't
clarify a lot of what he's going to do
so people are making assumptions about
what the plans would be and ten years
out no economist is going to be able to
tell you what's actually going to happen
because so much depends on the meantime
but there are a lot of misconceptions in
Trump's plant about trade as well first
that it's a zero-sum game and that we
are worse off because we import more
than we export and also for example
China he rails against the Chinese but
Chinese imports are actually going down
not going up forty percent of the
content of Mexican imports into the
United States through NAFTA its products
made in the u.s. sent there and
reassembled into things so there are a
lot of analysis of his plans that try to
take those things into account that his
plan doesn't when you take into account
that what he said there in the debate
comparing us to India and to China those
are emerging markets they're supposed to
be growing at eight nine six seven
percent talk about the distinction
between that and the growth that we see
here which that last reads two and a
half percent there is no question that
the u.s. is growing more slowly than it
has historically and it's growing more
slowly out of a recession this is a
different kind of recession and if you
look at Rogoff and Reinhart work they
would they predicted this that because
it's a financial recession you're going
to have slower growth but that you can't
compare the percentage gains as you say
for emerging markets and it's the
fallacy of using percentages because
they're coming from such a low base that
growth is on a percentage wise going to
be faster than in the US the US we hope
can get back to growing more quickly but
it doesn't compare with what's going on
in China like another sharp difference
between mr. Trump and mrs. Clinton are
the extent to which they would cut back
on regulation and one of the things that
mr. Trump says is if we cut back a
regulation we will get growth out of
that Hillary Clinton gives no indication
she's interest in that and as we talked
two hours the business community this
seems to be pretty important to them in
their view it's always important to them
you look at the surveys going back 20 30
40 50 years they always cite regulation
as a headwind now the Obama
administration has increased regulation
and so there is a cost to business but
it's very
to quantify and part of the problem with
the Trump plan is that he doesn't say
what regulations he would cut he just
says I'm going to cut regulations so
what does that actually mean for the
economy how do you measure it you could
pull the number out of the air but
unless you tell us exactly how you're
going to change things and another thing
to keep in mind when you talk about
cutting regulation you've got to balance
the other side suppose you take a steel
plant and say you were going to cut your
regulation you don't have to install
scrubbers okay that saves the steel
plant a million dollars but what about
the guy who makes the scrubbers that's a
million dollars business he's lost so
it's very hard to balance all those
things out in the economic models